danny duffy makes the start tonight yeah
but you know danny duffy he's not just
your average left-hander he's really
pitching at a high level right now for
cedric mullins in his six-game hit
streak
the american league hits leader 106
before the break and a breaking ball
inside here loop to left field and
cedric mullen starts the second half
exactly how you'd think he would
with a base hit number 107 of his
all-star season now austin hayes
and he'll ground one out to alberto the
former oriole and that's a 4-3 double
play
[Applause]
then comes a pitch and a line drive off
duffy that hurt he's limping around it
deflects out to lopez who throws to
first in time and now it remains to be
seen
whether or not that's the last pitch
that duffy will throw tonight
face left-hander keegan yeah keegan
naked 26 years old el salvador perez
begins the second half for the runner in
scoring position
and a ground ball headed for right field
and under the glove of mount castle the
first baseman wait around third and he
will score so perez with a pitch away
didn't try to pull it and the royals
jump in front one to nothing ben and
tendy it's a lefty lefty matchup
two two pitch outside edge strike three
call
ache in pain of the outside corner a 94
mile an hour fastball so he's got his
first strikeout but here's dozier
and aiken blows one by him
three pitches three strikes 94 to get
him
it's good to see danny duffy out there
he was limping badly
after taking a shot off of his left leg
right-handed batter
and he takes on the outside corner
strike three call
so after getting whacked on the ankle
boy inning number two it's a breeze for
duffy down go the birds
line shot over the glove of the third
baseman and up the left field line
solaire around second on his way to
third and he'll stop there on the double
by alberto
taylor will bat with runners second and
third and the birds will bring their
infield in 3-2 pitch this is yank to
third with the infield in goodyear is
checks third now guns defers to take
care of taylor great opportunity for
nikki lopez a 279 hitter against lefties
good job good number there
and on the hands but he pulls it into
right field
he will drive in one
here comes alberto and he will drive in
two
and he will take second base
nikki lopez finds a way again a solid
liner into right field for a hit on a
3-2 pitch the royals now lead three to
nothing
grounded fair
and that'll get nikki lopez to the plate
the royals have three in the second
inning and they lead four nothing
so now perez who's single to right and
drove in field in the first
runner at third with mere field coming
down the line
perez hits a shot into left field here
comes marifield it's five to nothing
and perez and two at bats has driven in
merrifield both times
so now they're loaded for the tenth time
this year the royals bat around
brings up solaire a second time in the
inning and would love a grand slam right
here bases are full
and solaire hits one high
and not deep enough to left
hayes and the orioles are going to get
out of it that ball carried
but stayed in the field of play
anz roberto wisely
advances
to third and so whitmerfield up there
now with first and third one down with
already a single a double he drove
interrupt with that double in the second
inning you scored two of the royals five
runs
stay light
that'll get a run home maybe more
and it's going to be caught on a great
running play by santonder
but deep enough to get alberto down from
third
and the royals have scored in each of
the first three innings
it is six nothing
and that wild pitch will move mullen to
third and hayes to second with nobody
out
2-2 mancini chops it's a roller over to
third toss across
tags mancini in time but cedric mullins
comes home and the orioles get on the
board they cut the lead 6-1 in the
fourth
3-2 against severino zimmer to the plate
severino smacks it to deep center field
taylor going back on the track this ball
bangs off the led board severino will
end up at second base with the double
got him to chase a slider salvi's gonna
have to throw him out
he does
and that's the inning
so zimmer works around the one out
double the royals lead 6-1
[Music]
and the royals have
a new hurler
and he is
josh stalmon and he gets to face cedric
mullins
got him
when he weighed him out
good breaking ball
and now stomach will get austin hayes
curveball is in there for a called third
strike
ostamon has struck out the first two
both with the curve
now chopped out to nikki again he gets a
nice big hop and that's the inning three
up three down against stomat in the
sixth
and the royals have at the corners with
two down
here's the throw to second base oh ben
and tandy fell down and severino cuts
him down
it almost looked like ben and tindy
realized he was going to be out he
wanted to put the brakes on and maybe
create a rundown for mirrorfield to
score from third base but no chance
pedro severino comes up with a cannon to
pat vallejo been intended down and the
orioles are off the field
four pitch walk to michael a taylor puts
him in first and second and that brings
up the number nine hitter nikki lopez
who drove in two
and the one-two pitch and a swing and he
shoots it to left-center and that's
gonna drop for a hit
here comes solaire around third to score
they're gonna wave taylor around as the
ball gets away
nikki got to second and as the ball gets
away he's going to go all the way to
third two more royals score and the lead
is eight to one
and here is with merefield
and now a base hit into left field and
whit merrifield begins the second half
with a four hit three rbi game
ninth career game with at least four
hits for wood merrifield and the royals
lead 9-1
that's blasted to left by severino it is
out of here
good power stroke tonight
for pedro severino doubled in a home run
in his first game out of the break
and number four for sebby making number
five makes it nine to two
[Applause]
three and two he'll be hacking
and it's a line drive base hit into left
field and on his way to third
santandar is out
a much better way to end the game
that's why baltimore has just lost their
62nd game
9-2 royals win